Çeviri: Ufuk Elif Rodoplu
Gözden geçirme: Suleyman Cengiz
Aranızda kız kardeşi olan var mı?
Veya ablası?
Benim de bir kız kardeşim var.
Bu benim kız kardeşim, Simay.
Aramızda beş buçuk yaş var.
Ve çocukluğumun mutlu geçmesini,
şu an sahip olduğum karakteri, kişiliği
ben Simay'a borçluyum.
Ve Simay'ın mutlu olması, başarılı olması,
kendi potansiyelini gerçekleştirmesi
benim için gerçekten çok önemli.
Simay üç sene önce üniversiteye girdi.
Sosyoloji okumak üzere.
Ve belli bir süre sonra cinsiyet
rollerinden konuşmaya başladı.
Aslında biz doğduğumuzda
cinsiyetimize göre,
ne yapabileceğimiz,
ne yapamayacağımız belirleniyor.
'Kadın doğulmuyor, kadın olunuyor.' dedi.
Ne demek kadın doğulmuyor, kadın olunuyor?
Ne aslında tam olarak bu cinsiyet rolleri?
Kadın evde oturur,
erkek eve ekmek getirir.
Erkek başarılı olur, kadın
başarılı erkeğin arkasında olur.
Kadın duygusaldır, erkek güçlüdür.
Kadın ev işlerini yapar, erkek ev
işlerini yapmaya yardımcı olur.
Hatta Google bile aslında
bu oyuna alet oldu.
Bunu daha önce göreniniz,
karşılaşanınız var mı bilmiyorum.
Liseden bir arkadaşımın Facebook'ta
paylaşmasıyla ortaya çıktı.
Google translate'e
'o ev işleri yapıyor' dediğinizde
'she is doing housework'
diye çeviriyorken,
'o bir bilim insanı'nı
çevirmesini istediğinizde,
'he is a scientist' diyor.
Peki bu cinsiyet rolleri
ne zaman başlıyor?
Bir araştırma yapıyorlar.
Bütün çocuk kitaplarını alıyorlar,
araştırmaya başlıyorlar.
Bu kitaplar arasında karakteri sadece
kadın olanları bir kenara ayırıyorlar.
Bunlar arasında da prenses
olmayanları bir kenara ayırıyorlar.
Ve bu kitaplar, bütün çocuk kitaplarının
sadece %5'i oluyor.
Böyle büyüyen kız çocukları da
gelecekte hayallerini gerçekleştirmek için
hep birilerine, aslında bir prense
ihtiyaç duyuyor.
Peki bu öğrenimlerle büyüyen yetişkinler
ileride nasıl bir algıya sahip oluyor?
Columbia Business School'da Frank Flynn
diye bir hoca yine bir araştırma yapıyor.
Heidi Roizen isimli,
inanılmaz başarılı bir kadın var.
Onun hikayesini öğrencilerinin
bir kısmına veriyor.
Sonra aynı hikayenin karakter ismini
'Howard'a çevirerek
diğer bir kısmına veriyor.
Ve sonuçta öğrenciler, Howard'ı çok daha
sempatik ve sevilebilir buluyorken
Heidi'yi itici ve agresif buluyorlar.
Peki Türkiye'de durum nasıl?
Halka açık şirketlerimizde
2773 yönetim kurulu üyesi var.
Bunların sadece %14'ü kadın.
İş gücünde olmayan, iş de aramayan
28 milyon insanımız. var.
Bunun 20 milyonu kadın.
Kayıtlı 1,5 milyon yöneticimiz var,
sadece 195 bini kadın.
Peki bu bize aslında neye mal oluyor?
STK dünyasındaki Itır Erhalt'lara,
iş dünyasındaki Güler Sabancı'lara,
Leyla Alaton'lara,
spor dünyasındaki Çağla Büyükakçay'lara,
ve bilim dünyasındaki
Canan Dağdeviren'lere mal oluyor.
Bizim daha nice gurur duyabileceğimiz,
ilham alabileceğimiz böyle kadın
rol modeller olabilecekken,
aslında biz bunlardan mahrum kalıyoruz.
Peki, sosyal normlar değiştirilemez mi?
Bu böyle gelmiş ve hep böyle gider mi?
1950'lerin, 60'ların ortalarına kadar,
yine doğduğunda kontrol
edemediğin bir değişken olan
ten renkleri yüzünden
siyahi vatandaşlar Amerika'da
köle muamelesi görüyordu.
Bırakın ikinci sınıf vatandaş olmayı,
bırakın yönetim kurullarına girmeyi,
bu insanlar kendi ülkelerinde sokakta
özgürce dolaşamıyordu bile.
1968 yılında bir siyahi lider
'Bir hayalim var' diyerek
bir hareket, bir akım başlattı.
Ama sadece beyazlar da
ona destek verdiği zaman
bu hayal büyüdü ve 2008 yılında
siyahi bir vatandaş
bu ülkenin başkanı olabildi.
Tabii ki hiçbir problem
bir anda çözülmüyor.
Belki de hiçbir problem hiçbir
zaman kökten çözülmüyor.
Ama biz ne yapabiliriz?
Üç tane çağrım var.
İlk çağrım erkeklere.
Bir sürü kadınla konuştum.
Hiçbir kadının talebi
pozitif ayrımcılık değil.
İstedikleri tek şey
ayrımcılık yapılmaması.
O yüzden verdiğimiz her kararda,
her söylemimizde
cinsiyet filtresinden
geçirmediğimizden emin olalım.
İkinci çağrım kadınlara.
Bu konunun bütünsel bir
yaklaşım gerektirdiğine
lütfen emin olun.
Çözümün parçası olmaya
çalışan erkekleri dışlamayın.
Onları da kapsayın, onları da kucaklayın.
Son çağrım ise aslında hepimize.
Çünkü alttan gelen jenerasyonun nasıl
yetişeceğine karar vermek bizim elimizde.
Çocuklarımızın cinsiyeti ne olursa olsun
'Sen bunu yapabilirsin.',
'Sen bunu yapamazsın.'
diye kısıtlamalar koymak yerine,
bütün opsiyonları onlara açabilirsek
belki de bir şeylerin iyiye doğru
gitmesine vesile olabiliriz.
Örneğin kızlarımıza ana karakterlerin
sadece prenses olduğu
hikayeleri okumak yerine,
bu elimde görmüş olduğunuz kitap gibi
dünyada farklı alanlarda başarılı olmuş
kadınların hikayelerinden oluşan
'Asi Kızlara Uykudan Önce Hikayeler'
kitabını okuyabiliriz.
Böylelikle kızlarımız bu kadınlardan
ilham alarak büyüyebilir.
Anne ve babalarımız,
bizlere hayatta hiçbir şeyin
sadece siyah veya sadece beyaz
olmadığını öğretti.
Belki şimdi de bizler hayatta hiç kimsenin
sadece pembe veya sadece mavi
olmadığını öğretebiliriz.
Teşekkürler.